hi Wes in our last video Sarah and I
told the story of how we narrowed down
the requirements and designed a user
interface for our YouTube comment
Tracker app yeah Sarah's method for
creating user interfaces together as a
group was fun you should check out that
video if you're into user interface
design
all right so we got to the point where
we had a mocked up user interface next
we needed to decide on which Google
products to include when building this
product yeah we have some great
discussions and I think we ended up with
a pretty good architecture so stay tuned
and we'll take you through that decision
process
[Music]
so a quick recap we needed a web app
that would help us stay on top of
comments for our YouTube videos we've
shot over 100 videos and we can't
possibly click into every video every
day to see if there are new comments it
would just take too long it would be too
difficult to remember which comments
were new since the last time we looked
now we needed a new dashboard to track
all of our videos so with Sarah's helped
me narrow down to these three use cases
then I created a user interface mock-up
it was sat down as a group and refined
it simplified it took out a bunch of
buttons yeah and now the question was
which Google Cloud product should we use
to build our app there are over 100 to
choose from ah yes uh now if I remember
correctly uh Wes you drew this picture I
love this picture because we have
YouTube on one side the YouTube API can
tell us about new comments made by
viewers and then on the other side we
need to present a web-based dashboard to
users who want to read new comments as
they come in and that's like people like
you and me right so Sarah you and I sat
down to fill out this architecture
diagram Samurai kept hammering on
Simplicity make it as simple as humanly
possible so could the web app just call
the YouTube API directly that way we
wouldn't need anything else in this
diagram
that was a really good question and it
spurred a useful discussion it turns out
the first use case here talks about
calling out new comments that haven't
been seen yet so we need us to somehow
remember what comments each user has
already seen yeah we considered storing
that in the web browser's local storage
but that storage is too easy to lose for
example if you switch to a new computer
or a new phone well you don't want the
app to show you the same comments all
over again right so we need a database
in the cloud the first question is SQL
or nosql database well we said this is a
view and update tool not a reporting
tool so each user will only need to see
their own data and that is which
comments they've already marked as read
this means that each page in the web app
will need to read dozens and hundreds of
Records not thousands or Millions so a
relational database is not required yeah
I remember that discussion if we could
pick either typo database we said we
might as well do nosql because it
requires less setup and less code also
Google's nosql databases have three
tiers yeah and if we go with nosql and
Google Cloud the default choice is cloud
firestore but then the question becomes
data store mode or firestore native mode
right we found this page that helps you
choose between the two modes it looks
like our app could actually use either
so we picked firestore native mode
because we felt that writing queries for
that is a little bit easier we also have
folks on the team who are familiar with
mongodb and the firestore native mode
API is kind of similar to that and if I
remember correctly that started a
different discussion firestore native
mode exposes an API that web apps can
access directly so we could potentially
avoid having to write any server-side
code that is a really compelling feature
less code means fewer bugs and less
maintenance work
but we figured that the web app doesn't
need all the data returned by the
YouTube API we could get a more
responsive client if we crunch the
numbers in server-side code first and
only send the processed results to the
client all right so server-side code it
is I had hoped we could do without it
now the question was where should that
code run we know that we wanted
serverless to minimize Ops work and
maximize uptime and not have to think
about machines or VMS but should we run
our code on app engine Cloud functions
or Cloud run
we figured we'd need a pretty rich
server-side API with many endpoints that
means we'd probably want to use express
flask or similar server side framework
yeah and we've seen in previous projects
that app engine and Cloud Run play well
with those Frameworks Cloud functions is
a little bit different
right it comes with its own framework
and that makes Cloud functions great for
the use case of I have some code I
wanted to run in the cloud when I hit
this particular URL
it's not meant for building complex apis
so we were down to app engine or Cloud
run
well containers have beencome the
standard way of packaging and deploying
Cloud applications over the last decade
so we'd like to use them on this project
so that other developers could help us
maintain it Cloud run supports
containers well and offers a streamlined
CI CD workflow once our code is in a
container on cloud run we could move it
later to a virtual machine or kubernetes
if we feel like we needed more control I
agree that containers are really popular
but not everyone on our team is really
familiar with them yeah that's fine with
Cloud run you can either Define your own
container in a Docker file and then
build it or you could submit that source
code to Google and we'll do that for you
using Cloud build packs so you don't
have to know anything about containers
at all
love it that makes it easier so Cloud
run it is all right so now we know where
our server side code should run but we
had to make another decision let's say
the user looks at a list of new YouTube
comments in their web browser should the
HTML for that list be generated on the
server by Cloud run or in a web browser
by client-side JavaScript right you and
I've been around Wes so we're both
comfortable with generating HTML on the
server you can do that with Django
laravel asp.net Ruby and rails and other
server-side Frameworks yep those are all
good and they have stood the test of
time but we figured that the UI would be
quite Dynamic for example when the user
marks a comment as read we'd like the UI
to update instantly instead of having to
do a round trip to the server to get a
new HTML page so we decided on
generating the HTML on the client that
meant we had to choose a client-side
framework angular react and view JS are
three popular Frameworks now the choice
here was pretty easy if I remember
correctly well yep our team only has
experience with view.js so that's what
we picked I'm sure any framework would
have worked but we wanted to keep things
easy for us so now that we have a pretty
smart client that generates its own HTML
how does it get the data from the server
a rest API is an easy way to do it we
sat down and defined these rest
endpoints that we thought we'd need we
actually got many of them right but we
had to add some more later on as we
understood the problem better yeah and
as we created that list of rest
endpoints we noticed that many of them
are done in the context of a user for
example the get slash playlist called
should return playlist that the current
user is subscribing to if you and I make
that call the results should be
different because we're looking at
different playlists
right right uh we realized that the
server set code would need a way to
authenticate the user so it could return
that user's playlist and not someone
else's
but building a login subsystem storing
users passwords dealing with lost
passwords and so on that's a lot of work
definitely fortunately there are lots of
different tools that Google cloud has
that can help you so we took a closer
look at Google sign in Firebase
authentication and Cloud identity
platform yep Google sign in is easy to
work with but it only supports Google
identities we wanted users to be able to
log in with their accounts from Facebook
Twitter Microsoft and so on yeah
Firebase auth and Cloud identity
platform both support non-google
accounts as we read upon them we saw
that identity platform is similar to
Firebase auth but it adds some nice
Enterprise features for example you can
require users to use two-factor
authentication and it comes with a nice
99.95 SLA so we picked identity platform
it's nice not to have to build another
login systems I built enough of those
earlier in my career but Wes we needed
to make one more decision right the web
browser needs to download the HTML CSS
and JavaScript files from somewhere so
we have at least two choices here
Firebase hosting or let Cloud run serve
the files
I really like Firebase hosting it's easy
to deploy your files to it and it
includes a CDN so users will get their
files quickly but we decided on serving
the files from cloud run I'm still a
little annoyed by that uh why did we
ever do that Wes well remember what
Sarah said let's keep things simple and
use as few tools as possible also we
figured that we and our co-workers who
are based in the US West Coast could use
the app if we deploy to the cloud run
service to one of the US West zones we
get pretty good performance even without
a CDN yeah yeah yeah I guess I can add
Firebase hosting in version two of that
I'm sure you will Martin
and that's how we designed the
architecture for our application thanks
for tuning in if you have any questions
for us or requests for topics in future
episodes please add them to the comments
and stay tuned for the next episode
where we will start implementing this
application until then
[Music]